[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon
if you'd like to help support my channel
and get early access to every video
consider becoming a patron at
patreon.com second thought
let me just show you that on paper
danielle and kristen sills are the
perfect first time home buyers
they've upped their budget and widened
their search of the boston area
but the last house they bid on had 29
offers
it sold for about 70 or 80 thousand over
what the asking price was
and it was a 1200 square foot home
finding an affordable apartment was hard
enough before the pandemic right
but now things are even worse some are
calling it a crisis the shortage is now
critical affordable so-called class c
apartments are 96 percent occupied
nationally
when they go shopping the inventory the
active listings they can choose from are
down about 30 percent from this time
last year that's just
a staggering shortage of homes on the
market right now
he compares this with what happened
during the subprime mortgage crisis a
decade ago
millions of homeowners defaulted on
their mortgages and investors came in to
buy the properties and convert them
into rental housing so you're going to
see a lot more of this soon
[Music]
as you watch this video you're probably
sitting somewhere with a roof over your
head
for many of you it's probably your home
either that or you're watching it work
in which case i applaud you for stealing
back some of your extracted value
shelter is one of the most critical
needs of almost every species on earth
including humans it's integral to the
american dream
a modest home with a white picket fence
two and a half kids and so on
homelessness is rightly seen as
something society needs to address
as most decent people feel that no one
should go without shelter in our modern
era
and yet despite the importance of
housing and the significance we place on
having somewhere to call home
it seems that the us is on a collision
course with another housing crisis
it may not take exactly the same form as
the housing crash of the great recession
but it is coming and it's not looking
good in this episode
we'll explore the state of housing in
the u.s and consider what factors are
feeding this growing problem
before we get into the causes of this
looming housing crisis
let's take a look at a few statistics if
you look at the housing market today
you'll notice a few things first there
aren't many single-family houses to be
had
people just aren't selling the houses
that do go up for sale
are snapped up incredibly quickly
typically within a week or even a couple
of days
having to offer tens of thousands of
dollars over the listing price has
become the norm if you want to actually
have a chance of having the winning bid
if you owned a home and you put it up
for sale today odds are you'd have at
least a handful of offers by the end of
the day
and many of them would be well over the
asking price month-over-month price
increases are now exceeding even the
absurd levels we saw in 2006
and we all know what happened shortly
after that what's going on here
a big part of the problem is that the
housing market is incredibly short on
supply
pace of housing production has slowed
dramatically contributing to an already
serious lack of housing
this is partly due to a shortage of
construction materials
and partly just a continuation of the
trend of producing fewer and fewer homes
per year
as of 2021 the us faces a shortage of
roughly 7 million homes
that's a lot of demand but a housing
shortage isn't the only problem here
the big picture is this young people are
trying to buy affordable homes
but the prices for even the most modest
quote starter homes are out of reach
these prices have been driven up by
institutional money pouring into the
housing market to snatch up homes as
investment properties
including the homes of those recently
evicted during the pandemic
to make matters worse some large
investment firms are lobbying to end
eviction protections so that they can
acquire
even more houses adding to the housing
demand and homelessness problems at the
same time
with single family homes out of reach
for the average working american
the media has begun trying to frame
perpetual renting as a good thing
something that benefits young people the
problem there
is that even renting is becoming
prohibitively expensive
there are now officially zero counties
in the entire country where a worker
earning the federal minimum wage can
afford a one-bedroom apartment
even for those making significantly more
than minimum wage
things are looking pretty grim there's a
common joke that goes something like
the bank said i couldn't afford an 1800
a month mortgage
so now i pay 3 000 a month in rent the
cherry on top
is the true unemployment rate if we take
the lysep definition for unemployment
someone who is looking for a full-time
job that pays a living wage but cannot
find one
then the true rate of unemployment in
the u.s currently sits at a staggering
23.7 percent
so even if quote affordable housing were
available
it likely wouldn't be affordable because
nearly a full quarter of americans can't
find a job that pays a living wage
with that context out of the way let's
look at how these problems combine to
form the perfect storm for economic
meltdown
we'll start with everyone's favorite bad
guys the billionaires
it should come as no surprise that the
people putting in bids at 60
80 100 000 over asking price are not
your average person
they're typically the ultra wealthy
usually through investment firms or
other real estate poaching groups
let's take charles coke as an example
one of the billionaire koch brothers
charles has donated millions of dollars
to three conservative organizations
spearheading the push to eliminate covet
eviction protections
this alone would be reprehensible but
since the beginning of the pandemic
he's also been heavily investing in real
estate snatching up homes left and right
to add to his massive portfolio of
assets
among them the homes of the evicted and
desperate in april 2020
he dumped 200 million dollars into
amherst holdings
a company which brags that has acquired
over 30 000 homes since 2012.
koch real estate investments was also
among the investment groups that
recently bought an ownership stake in
smart rent
a landlord technology company charles
koch is not alone in this scheme
billionaires investment firms and giant
corporations are buying up as many homes
as they possibly can which is driving
prices way beyond the reach of the
average american
and they're also betting big on the
lucrative future of the rental market
it should be clear that very few normal
people are going to be able to afford to
make offers on homes that exceed the
asking
price by tens or even hundreds of
thousands of dollars
but some media outlets would have you
believe that giant real estate firms
aren't the bad guys here
for example vox put out an article
saying things like
everybody wants to blame blackrock and
wall street isn't to blame for the
chaotic housing market
to give them the benefit of the doubt
yes obviously everything has multiple
variables which influence material
reality
but it's a little on the nose to say
blackrock is good actually
when the ceo of vox investor general
atlantic is on the board of directors
at blackrock and even if that weren't
the case
the vox article makes some strange
assertions claiming for example that
institutional investors just aren't that
interested in single-family homes
this is demonstrably false as firms like
blackrock have bought up hundreds of
thousands of single-family homes since
the great recession
and they continue to hold them hostage
on the rental market
then there's airbnb if you go on
vacation odds are you'll find dozens of
cute freshly renovated two-bedroom units
to choose from
entire neighborhoods empty except for
out-of-state license plates
there's no such thing as an affordable
home anymore
they've all been bought up whether by
institutional investors or wannabe real
estate moguls
and turned into airbnbs or rentals and
very few new ones are being built
in fact there's a new trend of building
suburban neighborhoods not with the
intention of selling the homes
but of selling the entire development to
investment firms who then rent out the
houses
vox isn't the only instance of media
trying to manufacture consent for
endless renting
the wall street journal says it's
generational preferences that are
pushing young people to rent instead of
buying a home
but it's not preference at all most
young people would love to have the
stability of owning a home
especially when mortgages are now
typically much lower than rent prices in
the same area
but they've been priced out of home
ownership and now
it's looking like they're going to be
priced out of renting too
companies that have a stake in people
renting are pushing for an end to home
ownership
bloomberg says things like rising real
estate prices are stoking fears that
homeownership
long considered a core component of the
american dream is slipping out of reach
for low and moderate income americans
that may be so but a nation of renters
is not something to fear
in fact it's the opposite they end their
article with
this country was always more about new
frontiers than comfortable settlements
anyway
which translates as you will suffer and
never be able to afford a home and
that's good because it's the american
way
so we have entire generations of
americans no longer being able to afford
single-family homes we have rapidly
increasing rent prices to the point
where an eviction crisis is very likely
large corporations are buying up all the
available housing and actively trying to
get more people evicted so they can
snatch up their homes too
new communities are being developed not
to be used for affordable housing
but explicitly for the purpose of making
a new suburban renter class that is held
hostage by landlords and faceless
investment firms
and the media is telling us that
actually this is what we want and that
stability and building equity is bad
this all adds up to one serious economic
crisis looming on the horizon
it's always hard to predict exactly what
form the fallout will take
but it's usually a safe assumption that
the brunt of the suffering will fall
upon
those who have little say in the matter
lower income people who are just trying
to get by
the major players who are manipulating
the market and causing these problems
will suffer no consequences
and if the great recession is anything
to go by they will actually dramatically
increase their wealth at the expense of
the rest of the population
well this all sounds pretty bad what's
the solution here
how can we avoid another massive
economic collapse
historically speaking we can't
capitalism is built on the maintenance
of cycles of boom and bust
and they're fairly predictable in their
timing these crises are becoming more
frequent and more damaging to the
average person
but also more lucrative for the ruling
class and if we know anything about
capitalism
it's that when the ruling class is
benefiting from something it will not
change without a massive
drawn-out struggle if you're a young
person or a person of any age really
if you're looking for a home i don't
think it would be wise to try to buy one
now i know it's easy to say save more
money
but do what you can to squirrel away a
few bucks here and there
rent will continue to go up but the
chaos surrounding single-family homes
can't last forever
it's unsustainable even in the fairly
short term i think a crash of some sort
is likely
and hopefully if we can ride out the
storm housing prices might come down
somewhat afterwards
the giant real estate firms will have
added many new properties to their
portfolio
but it's very unlikely that they will
have bought them all
once supply chains recover from the
pandemic construction materials become
more available
and the home buying frenzy dies down a
little bit hopefully there will be some
homes
available for first-time buyers in the
meantime
we have some actions we need to take
first we need to push back against the
media talking points about generational
preferences
and the benefits of renting they support
a predatory exploitative status quo that
we should not accept
if they want us to rent we need to
demand affordable apartment housing with
rates that only increase with inflation
not at the whims of parasitic landlords
we also need to remember that
once upon a time owning a home was
within reach for just about every
american
back in the 50s a suburban home only
cost two or three times the average
salary
which meant that not only could people
easily afford them
they could pay them off in a matter of a
few years rather than over the course of
three decades
like almost everything else under modern
capitalism housing has shifted from
being seen as a basic necessity
to a valuable commodity from which the
wealthy can extract
massive profits the best thing we can do
right now is continue to fight evictions
organize tenants unions to build
bargaining power against the landlords
fight for higher wages across the
country and support our neighbors
however we can
you are an individual but you're also a
member of one of two classes
either the working class or the
capitalist class
if you do not own the means by which
capital is produced
a factory an office building a block of
apartments a large company
you are a member of the working class
and that means your fight is the same as
the people at risk of eviction
or who make 7.25 an hour or who can't
afford their medical bills
only by acting in solidarity with your
class can you make a significant
impact if you do own the means of
production if you have wealth at your
disposal
we need you too we wouldn't have had
marks without angles
donate to mutual aid funds buy and
distribute copies of socialist books
use your free time to help in whatever
ways you can everyone has a role to play
and in the housing crisis or any other
fight organizing
is key to victory i mentioned at the
beginning of this video that this kind
of content
while very important is something that
sponsors won't touch
in order to pay the bills and keep this
channel running i rely on adsense
revenue
sponsors and donations from generous
viewers by producing explicitly
anti-capitalist content
i lose out on both sponsors and adsense
if you enjoy the kind of videos i'm
producing
and you're able to chip in even a dollar
a month i would greatly appreciate the
support
you can find my patreon page join our
growing discord server
and get early access to every episode at
patreon.com
second thought if you enjoyed this video
consider dropping a like
if you hated it a thumbs down you can
check out my previous episodes by
clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
you